Nobel laureates excellencies ladies and
gentlemen it's a great pleasure and
privilege for me to welcome you all to
Karolinska Institutet South America for
the 2017 Nobel lectures in Physiology or
medicine
my name is Ollie Peterson and the rector
vice-chancellor of Karolinska Institutet
during the Nobel Week and particularly
during the Nobel lectures we celebrate
science and rejoice at the unique
contributions of some truly exceptional
individuals because research is a way of
quenching of a thirst for knowledge
testing around limits and having an
outlet for our creativity and
competitive spirit within Physiology or
medicine the ultimate goal is to achieve
scientific breakthroughs that change our
views of human health disease and normal
vital processes d low rates you have
surely contributed to this today it's an
honor for me to extend my warmest
welcome on behalf of Karolinska
Institute to Jeff Hall Michael rosebush
and Michael Young the 2017 Nobel
laureates in Physiology or medicine they
are receiving the Nobel Prize for their
discoveries on molecular mechanisms
controlling the circadian rhythm without
further ado and I'll call upon Julian
Serrat professor of clinical integrity
physiology and member of the Nobel
Committee for Physiology or medicine she
will introduce the laureates
Lynne the floor is yours
your excellencies vice-chancellor
esteemed laureates dear colleagues
ladies and gentlemen we are now at a
high point in the Nobel Week the Nobel
lectures on behalf of the Nobel assembly
that Karolinska Institutet it is a great
honor for me to introduce the 2017 Nobel
laureates in Physiology or medicine
Jeffery Hall Michael Ross fash and
Michael Young they have received this
year's Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine for their discoveries of
molecular mechanisms controlling the
circadian rhythm life on Earth is
adapted to the rotation of our planets
for many years we have known that living
organisms including humans have an
internal biological clock that helps
them anticipate and adapt to the regular
rhythm of the day but how does this
clock actually work Jeff Hall Michael
Ross Bosh and Michael Young were able to
peek inside our biological clock and
elucidate it its inner workings their
discoveries explain how plants animals
and humans adapt their biological rhythm
so that it's synchronized with the
Earth's rotations using their beloved
fruit fly as a model organism this
year's Nobel laureates isolated a gene
that controls the normal biological
rhythm they showed that this gene
encodes a protein that accumulates in
the cell during the night and then is
degraded during the day subsequently
they identified additional protein
components of this machinery exposing
the mechanism governing the
self-sustaining clockwork inside the
cell we now know that nearly all cells
in our body have an inner clock and to
quote one of the laureates Michael young
were just all a collection of clocks we
also know
that a large proportion of our genes are
regulated by the biological clock and
consequently a careful calibrated
circadian rhythm adapts our physiology
to the different phases of the day the
biological clock regulates critical
functions such as behavior hormone
levels sleep body temperature and
metabolism our well-being is affected
when there's a temporary mismatch
between our external environment and
this internal biological clock for
example when we travel across several
time zones and experience what's known
as jetlag we also know that chronic
misalignment between our lifestyle and
the rhythm dictated by our inner
timekeeper is associated with increased
increased risk for various diseases
since their seminal discoveries
circadian biology has developed into a
vast and highly dynamic research field
with implications for our health and our
well-being so in addition to this year's
Nobel Prize Jeff Hall Michael Ross Besh
and Michael Young have been awarded
numerous prizes along their
distinguished careers including the
Gruber Prize in neuroscience the Louisa
grouse Horwitz prize the Shaw prize the
Wiley Prize in biomedical sciences and
the Gardner foundation international
award and now as they say in the field
of chrono biology it is time to hear
from each of the laureates and I'm the
timekeeper for this afternoon's session
we'll hear three individual lectures and
this really is a unique opportunity for
us to gain first-hand insight into their
journeys and these journeys that have
led to their seminal discoveries of
mechanisms controlling the circadian
rhythm these journeys have likely been
fuelled by scientific inquiry little
mischief hard work teamwork maybe a
little friendly competition and of
course one cannot forget
their love of genetics and that of the
fruit fly so now I'll begin with the
introduction of the first of our three
laureates and this is professor emeritus
Jeffrey hall he's a geneticist in a
chronal biologist and he is a professor
emeritus of biology at Brandeis
University professor Hall received his
doctorate degree in 1971 at the
University of Washington in Seattle he
was a postdoc with Seymour Benzer who
was a pioneer in the field of genetics
and he performed this postdoc at the
California Institute of Technology he
joined the faculty at Brandeis
University in 1974 and in 2002 he became
associated with the University of Maine
he was elected into the US National
Academy of Sciences for his
revolutionary work in the field of
chrono biology professor Hall has spent
his career examining the neurological
components of fly courtship and
behavioral rhythms now I'd like to ask
you all to join me in welcoming this
year's Nobel laureate professor Jeff
Hall up to the stage and we will hear a
lecture from him entitled the little
flies multi-faceted basic research
coming out better than intended
professor Hall
[Applause]
do I just start talking you just start
talking okay so as Willy Loman would say
isn't this a remarkable thing that
alludes to the fact that I'm extremely
grateful and deeply honored for all of
what's going on here and this week
beyond this week whether or not the
whole deal makes my mind boggle at the
thought mind but this leads me to segue
into some claims that I'm gonna make
some additional remarks having to do
with gratitude in in certain general
crypto historical ways about various
predecessors that ended up being at
least loosely connected with the
research in question and further words
of gratitude to certain specific
biologists and geneticists so for
example not too long after I was
attempting to establish research at dear
old Brand X University in Northeast us
as a pleasant surprise to me I was
invited to give a presentation at the
National Drosophila meetings this had
been kick-started by my second mentor in
my time in the late 1950s estimable
geneticist named Larry Sandler rest in
peace and many years later I was invited
to speak at the Drosophila meeting in
the late 1970s or so by which time the
meeting had grown to be at least
numerically more significant and I was
wondering why did I receive such an
invitation I knew why because another
mentor of mine Dan Linsley a close
colleague of Sandler invited me as a
favor he was one of the meeting
organizers so I had just started
attempting to establish a research
enterprise studying at the time as you
heard brief mention fruit fly courtship
behavior studied potentially study about
genetically and therefore having the
potential further to dig into the neural
substrates of this kind of fruit fly
behavior so I was trying to fill out 30
minutes or so with something rather
about our first blush studies of
courtship even that much to say so a key
part of this presentation had to do with
a infamous courtship reproductive
behavioural mutant in Drosophila which
have been rattling around the fly world
for several years and nobody was
actually studying it of friends for good
reason but it did lead to the creation
of certain underground movies that
showed a group of this genetic variant
type in a wild frenzy of courtship like
interactions between and among the Flies
in this filthy film so one of the
members of the audience at this force
awfully meeting sitting near the front
quipped this is like I am curious yellow
forked that's a joke not a funny joke
but it has the benefit of referring to
one of my favorite movies they came out
of this country or maybe
as I'm curious blue and the final the
final feature of this clip the English
words yellow in forked makes an overt
reference to a certain type of genetic
variant in Drosophila of the chromosomal
type many genetic variants over the
years harking back to more than 100
years ago were above the level of genic
changes instead chromosomal level
changes anomalies with the designator
that included ice again yellow forked
okay so those movies meant a whole hell
of a lot to me certainly more than
various bear mountain eras which
included things like the protagonist
played checkers with death or something
I didn't understand any of that but the
the fellow who made this tasteless jape
from the audience was somebody who in
principle should be known about by many
in this room including those involved in
the prize awardee organization because
the fellow who said this who often
behaved like it was as a dirty dirty man
was Edward Louis who received this prize
in the mid-1990s for his work that
included a heavy dose of Drosophila
genetics and Edie Edie Lewis was a
student back when he was a baby he was a
student of one of the Giants in genetic
history won Alfred Sturtevant Sturdivant
was the academic offspring of Thomas
Hunt Morgan who was the first Restless
to be awarded this prize in the 1930s
and Morgan generated a variety of
academic
offspring notably a famed trio of what
you might call Morgan's f1 that included
Sturdivant and another member of this
trio was a another at the time fledgling
Drosophila geneticist named Hermann
Muller now Muller based on a discovery
he made at the University of Texas in
the middle south of the United States in
a ASUS of intellectual activity within
that state we're by the way Mike Young
whom you of course hear from today Mike
Young did his PhD thesis work at the
University of Texas
so Muller did work then which was seemed
to be very salient at the time at least
and that led to Muller being awarded
this prize in the 1940s for Muller to
accomplish what he did for his
prize-winning study it was
quintessential
for him to have designed and generated a
particular kind of Drosophila
chromosomal variant which made all the
difference for the performance of that
study this is a category of chromosomal
variant which I won't burden you with
detail wise which became one of the
great secret weapons of Joseph Oliver's
research over many many subsequent
decades without which a huge number of
Drosophila could have never done
anything if it hadn't been for this type
of chromosomal a base variant now back
to the matter of another type of
chromosomal variant that I've already
referred to that includes the
designators yellow in Fort Muller
it was Muller himself who generated that
now classic type of chromosomal variant
in the 1940s although it did not he
didn't get the Nobel Prize for that
it was for other features of his
genetically-based studies but these
chromosomal variants which were often
designed deliberately and constructed
via the usual cytogenetic mumbo-jumbo
were powerfully applicable to ask and
answer some genetic questions what I
call genetic genetics about hereditary
factors but the variants were maintained
survived down the generations the
fruit-fly generations and the human ones
and several of them turned out to be
massively applicable for other reasons
later on okay now the back to ed ed
Louis and irrespective of what he said
from the front row during that fruitful
meeting when I was rambling on about
courtship behavior that in here I need
to mention another of the third member
of Thomas on Morgan's famous trio is f1
this is Calvin Blackmon bridges who made
massive contributions in genetic history
including establishing major elements of
what is known as fruit Flight
cytogenetics observing and analyzing
chromosomes including chromosomes
contained in these aforementioned types
of genetic variants one my first mentor
in my time when I was an undergraduate
yes it was during the 30 Years War my
first mentor was his name was named
Burris in peace
Philip Ives and he was supervising a
small coterie of undergraduates and we
were doing meager little fruit fly
genetics projects and he was a superb
instructor massively enthusiastic
motivational he really taught us a whole
hell of a lot of what to do when a given
would be researched day but also he
imbued his charges with what I realized
later was described by the phrase the
lore of Drosophila the deep background
of research initially genetic genetics
involving this organism which goes back
more than a hundred years from now and
Ives like it Louis Ives was a student
working under Sturdivant in the
southwestern US and what some would call
I never would call the dumb blonde of
the United States near L near laa but in
any event one of Ives and Lewis's lab
mates was bridges when Morgan moved from
New York City northeastern us to the Los
Angeles area he brought in it was in the
late 1920s he brought with him
Sturdivant and bridges Muller as he
grumbled about for the rest of his life
was exiled to places like Texas and
Russia but anyway eyes told me when I
was beginning to get a little bit of a
feel about what fruit fly genetics can
ask an answer potentially Ives mentioned
that bridges who was his academic uncle
if you will bridges had the best I to
notice novel sports you could say
variance at the anatomical level he had
the best eye to detect these as he and
his lab mates would plow through these
enormous mounds of fruit flies under the
microscope searching for rare novel
anatomical changes and one of those that
bridges found back in New York in the
nineteen teens was immediately as all
the other sports immediately rolled into
their genetic
processes where they asked does this
anatomical change have a genetic
causation and might it be hard
specifiable that way and many of these
variants had that attribute and so based
on formal genetics they started to
create lots of information about the
nature of this insects genome with
regard to genetic variants including
genic variants in addition to
chromosomal level variants but this
particular genetic variant that bridges
which is quite subtle that bridges
detected in 1916 seemed as if it might
be also biologically interesting
potentially as opposed to just a an
extra genetic tool in the genetic
variant toolkit biologically interesting
compared for instance with some of these
variants that had for instance altered
eye color snore not necessary that
interesting biologically so Louis
working under Sturdivant with bridges as
his lab mate and with eyes as a nether
lab mate who divulged to me part of the
lore of Drosophila about what a great
eye Bridges himself had to notice novel
variants Louis began his career after
his PhD research studying purely genetic
genetic phenomena in Drosophila but a
while later Lewis made a lateral move
just as a duck might make a lateral move
all along into what I call part of my
internal argot biogenetics and he picked
up on bridges variant the one which
seemed to bridges and other of his lab
mates to be interesting potentially at
the biological level more than just
genetics itself and Louis for several
decades subsequently pounded away at the
factors pointed to by that bridges
variant and
additional related genetic variants
related genetically and biologically and
initiated the majority of his Louis's
career in studying the animals
development by taking a genetic approach
when I was fortunate to get to know IDI
well and realize that he was a
developmental geneticist par excellence
and a funky little fellow as well cute
as a button by the way Louis was at
Caltech toiling in absolute obscurity
even within that department be he was
ignored or disparaged in the main he was
kind of a recluse his members of his lab
I think was one other person and but
those who knew about Ed's presence said
on his behalf well it doesn't publish
anything this is now the early 70s he
had not published a paper since the mid
50s
they said he doesn't do that because
he's a perfectionist he demands absolute
thoroughness and perfection before he
puts pencil to paper and this got back
to Ed naturally and he once said to me
in private he said Jeff this is caca he
said I'm not publishing anything because
I haven't found anything in living
memory and that was reality but a few
years later in the late 70s ed burst
forth with a publication late 70s that
won him the Nobel Prize and this and
this was all based on the genetic
variant at at root found by bridges back
in the 19-teens
so this variant and many associated
variants including chromosome
aberrations mind you other categories
seem to say a whole hell of a lot about
how certain genes help construct this
organism beginning at the earliest stage
of development this paper 78 also had
strong evolutionary implications even in
the pre
Molecular era the relevant genetic
factors in Drosophila or else or had not
yet been identified
DNA wise okay so an example of how you
can muddle along and admit to yourself
that you're not getting anywhere but you
you hope that you're making a tad of
progress during a given half decade keep
going and something might will out as it
did in the case of IDI which is you know
thanks in part to his wherewithal going
back to morgan sturdivant with a lot of
ancillary help from Muller and naturally
bridges that that this whole project
that Ed was mired in when I first got to
know him was an example of something
coming up better that he intended or at
least expected but as you also heard a
mention of in the introductory remarks
another corner of the overall biogenetic
enterprise in principle a priori might
involve for safa behavior as opposed to
developments starting with a fertilized
egg most conspicuously postnatal
behavior after you get the mature adult
animal and so by a behavior biogenetics
was pioneered principally conspicuously
by the aforementioned Seymour Benzer
who by then had moved to Caltech and
took advantage of Ed Lewis's local
genetic and chromosomally based genetic
expertise so Benzer instead of just
imagining he might encounter the
occasional behavioral variant made a
systematic attempt to generate
behavioral variants from scratch and
systematically search for them the way
he did this the only way it would have
worked was to apply you guessed it the
aforementioned vivid EBU yellow forked
chromosomal variant
which made all the difference for this
mutant hunt to work and it did work and
several of these first blush behavioral
mutants ended up pointing to
well definable genes with interesting
products interesting products that
function on behalf of the animals post
natal activities behavior physiology in
her chemistry as the case may be but
aping the Benzer approach one year later
this is now the late 60s a student in
menzards lab Ronald J Konopka said I'm
gonna do the same thing the self st.
genetic tactic applying did I did at
that yellow fort once again very
powerfully applicable as came to be
realized decades after Muller generated
it he said I'm gonna search for novel
variants but in this case of a
particular type daily rhythm variants
that would show abnormalities or
anomalies of daily biological rhythms in
Drosophila and what Konopka did
therefore was kickstart perhaps
unwittingly then a tiny sub cottage
industry enterprise he kick-started what
is now in this century has become
industrial level research in chrono
genetics and molecular genetic
chronobiology including neurobiology the
Konopka was a rare bird and very adept
at what he was doing both in terms of
chrono biology and genetics thanks to
being mentored as ron was by lewis
largely but he wasn't absolutely alone
even though
chrono genetics was a tiny tiny subset
of the biogenetic enterprise because
shortly after Konopka initiated the
whole deal some fungal geneticists did
the same kind of thing they searched for
rhythm variants in a species of fungus
should be appreciated by many in this
room because working on this fungal
species Nawroz pura led to one of the
banner Nobel prizes in the history of
the whole deal
when George Beetle and Edward Tatum
realized that Norris for genetics is
aces but they weren't studying genetic
phenomena alone they were using neurons
for genetics to ask questions about not
just what is a gene if you know what a
gene is sitting there somewhere that's
not enough what is a gene doing what's
coming out of a gene and Beadle and
Tatum made major contributions to what
later became known as gene action and
which later on was often as a kind of a
aphorism DNA makes RNA makes protein ok
but Neurospora at least in part because
you can do fine genetics with that
species of fungus became also a chrono
genetic system in that fungus after
Konopka had initiated the fruit fly side
of things the Ross Perot chrono genetics
I have found in my opinion which is
infallible is aces but at a minimum I
was very glad and very appreciative of
becoming acquainted with the Nawroz for
a fungal folk who were studying rhythms
because at the early rhythm conferences
I went to and you could never imagine
the falter all at these conferences
coming from the lecterns in the front of
the room it was bigger the imagination
and I would be sitting next to the
Norris bro chrono geneticists in
question Jay Dunlap and Jennifer Loras
and we would be sitting there rolling
our eyes heavenward at what was coming
out of a given speaker and Jay or
Jennifer would lean sideways and say
yeah you're right forget about that that
is authentic chrono gibberish but every
once in a while they'd lean sideways and
say that's worth registering
and processing later at the bar so it
resumes rhythm research in part when you
get clear with various of the phenomena
and the norms and the jargon and so
forth rhythms are interesting I claim
lots of research is can be comes under
the heading of dry as dust often study
by professor dries dust but rhythms are
interesting in part because they're
accessible to researchers it's thing it
just seems neat that biological cells
and tissues can harbor clocks biological
clocks not electromechanical biological
what could they be and back when I and
Mike Ross fish Michael Ross Fisher Mike
young got into this nobody had a clue
what a clock could be composed over how
it might operate but we imagined we
imagined that taking a genetic and
eventually molecular genetic approach
the latter being quintessential
that we might contribute to
understanding how rhythms are
established and regulated and how do
they clunk along everyday all day
what am I out of time already I'm out of
my mind which that's not possible there
is no mind left but anyway this brings
me to another claim which is cavalier
and whimsical is that I think I believe
that this year with regard to this Prize
in Physiology or medicine oddly named
that there should be five awardees
there should be five awardees this year
in this category and one of them should
be the little flies which have
contributed also there can't be five
awardees that flouts the rules or as
Americans would say flaunts the rule
they most of them being illiterate but
but a warty number four should be the
little flies because as exemplified
they've created massive amounts of
biological in addition to genetic
knowledge going back more than a hundred
years of time and the fifth awardee
silly as this may sound should be the
phenomenon rhythmicity because rhythms
are arguably interesting and you've
already heard about why they should be
regarded as interesting and you're gonna
hear much more about that in meaningful
words and pictures from professors raw
special young but rhythms are
interesting and and as you'll be hearing
about they're ubiquitous among organisms
and even within a given type of organism
that they're universal attributes
descriptively seems to point to how
important they must be and as if they
may have in fact than one of the
earliest things that evolved as
Americans would say 6,000 years ago one
life arose here on the third Rock from
the Sun but to study for mutants with
abnormal rhythms in fruit flies and then
Neurospora and later a variety of other
organisms that those mutations where I
had interesting abnormalities but the
mutations causing the mutant rhythm
anomalies the mutations also pointed to
genes and as Michael had said even in in
private and even in mixed company Jewish
and Gentile that for this biogenetic
enterprise chrono genetics it was
quintessential you could never
meaningfully predict what these genes
would be about what kinds of products
would come out of them
unless the jeans and the products were
identified empirically by actual lab
work so the molecular side of the chrono
genetic Enterprise quintessentially
needed to become and did do molecular T
as well so the final thing I'll say here
having given a tip of the hat or so2
varies predecessors including my two
mentors and their associates who I
wished I were alive when bridges
Sturdevant and even Muller who I never
met I begged my mentors to introduce me
and they refused but many of my
predecessors that I did or did not have
anything to do with personally been a
hell of a lot to me but springing
forward into the 1980s and Beyond I
think it's worth mentioning that they're
actually of course can only be three
awardees in this category this year as
every year three or fewer but and the
three or T's are what in terms of
American research grant jargon RPI's the
3p is that stands for principal
investigator
perhaps the agita is correct although
not all P is actually investigate as you
meant but I part of my own internal
lingo was to refer to lab mates such as
in the lab of what I nominally
supervised and Michael did and Mike did
and those who still do or ai's actual
investigators and I I can't help give a
tip of the hat to a subset of these
those who voted with their feet in their
pocketbooks to travel long distances to
be part of this week of double D boo
such as people I can never forget and
never failed to appreciate chrono wise
at least like BAM Bo's carry aku and
Cathy
Sawicki and Ralston Eskie and Joel
Levine some of the major contributors to
the chrono genetic molecular
neurobehavioral and and then and then
when Michael Ross fish and I went half
of each of her lab joined forces one of
the great joys believe it or not even
I'm a terrible sourpuss but I really
genuinely joy coming to what I
laughingly called work because I
realized that there were all these fine
ai's nominally under me but also in
Michaels lab people I I know that some
of them have made this trip for this
week
like Paul Harden and Ravi alotta but
there was a really a doubling or more
than a doubling of a eyes with whom to
interact and a is in the two labs got to
do both in terms of vocational and
personal matters to have a large by lab
research group everybody studying in
various different ways an arguably
interesting phenomenon very study of all
in the the little flies and then later
and I'll never forget this and I'll
never fail to appreciate what she did
this is now vaunted professor Leslie
Voss Hall who was when I first met her
was in the early 90s was a baby
working Michael so uh Mike Young's lab
in New York City and at some dumb
meeting which are always done scientific
but the one thing I remember from that
meeting at the Leslie Vose all
single-handedly kick-started a situation
where the three labs the three chrono
genetic molecular chrono were beginning
to communicate and this made the whole
deal better professionally and
personally to get to know a is in Mike's
life such as professor now professor
voss hall and Amita Sehgal who is here
who traveled a long way and several
other AIS there are many many other eyes
among the three labs away have been
mentioned
because they didn't travel to Stockholm
or I am unaware that they did or didn't
but it was just I mean you know your
your supervisees make all the difference
in terms if anything is going to happen
and it's often just on a day-to-day
basis interesting and enjoyable to
interact with them even if the pie is
not really supervising like you know
Michael and I in one office of the other
sitting down and talking about sports
outcomes Agony's or something but
nonetheless the a is between two labs
and then with a third lab from the same
region of the United States but far away
it really became a three lab group in
terms of communication and even palpable
cooperation so the whole thing was I
think it did come out better than we
intended at least at the beginning going
back to the late seventies early
eighties but however it was going to
come out it was just it was really
almost sensually enjoyable to deal with
the little flies and all the potential
that they create including genetics and
then molecular and genomics and they
behaved in a very complex sophisticated
way more sophisticated than the behavior
of many humans which is like shooting
fish in a barrel
but but they they divulge it's almost
like in some mystical stupid way that
you said my god if you if you're gonna
work with me seriously and if you know
what you're doing and you care I'm gonna
give up a secret or two if you just keep
going even if for a while if nobody's
necessarily paying any attention as in
the case of the vaunted Edie Lewis rest
in peace
who was as self-admittedly
he was always very different fellow was
totally obscure even within his own
department until he burst forth with
studies which had
spectacular heuristic value to
understand not only Drosophila
development but developmental phenomena
underpinned by genetic factors in all
kinds of other animals Michael's just
waggling something at me is it it wasn't
quite an obscene gesture but it should
have been um but the same happened again
better than we intended that these fruit
fly chrono factors genic mutants
mutations molecular clones connected
with analogous and even literally
homologous factors way beyond the insect
arena which I don't think we would have
never particularly anticipated back in
the late 70s but Jesus to work on the
little flies and to be mentored in part
about the lore of Drosophila which
didn't really help it was just
interesting and it's kind of
motivational so the tip of my hat to all
these predecessors all these successors
and especially you know someday come on
guys give a prize to an invertebrate
it'll be it'll be funky but warranted so
I'm done well I'm really done in in life
as well as but if there's been any
attention I thank you for it
[Applause]